celle que j'accueille maintenant
triomphe dans le film de dominik moll
qui s'appelle harry un ami qui vous veut
du bien avec sergi lopez et mathilde
seigner
voici ce film art
j'ai fait mon choix je les ai gérard
darmon non méfiez-vous la tiennent leurs
liens attention à lui c'est le latino
lover type surtout maintenant qu'il a
les cheveux un peu plus grisonnant il
vous emballez plus non non non c'est non
bon alors vous ai découvert avec l'ennui
de cédric kahn avec charles berling et
arielle dombasle qui a eu le prix louis
delluc et justement on a beaucoup dit
enfin les gens 110 après l'ennui est ce
que c'est si votre premier film
est-ce que c'est l'actrice d'un rôle ou
est ce que finalement elle peut très
bien continuer une carrière au cinéma
alors c'était la deuxième solution
puisque vous avez fait un crime qui est
sorti en mai et là bientôt il ya ça ira
mieux demain de jeanne labrune qui va
sortir au mois de novembre
on savait déjà au moins trois films dont
vous n'êtes pas la crise d'un film de
toute façon alors si c'est vrai que
votre entrée dans le cinéma est assez
illustratif des facéties du sort c'est
un une histoire assez incroyable parce
que bon quand vous étiez petit comme
toutes les filles voulaient être actrice
vouliez être viviane lead en emporte le
vent exerce un garçon qui va être
viviane oui mais enfin ça je le dire aux
parents que c'est un peu plus compliqué
voilà mais bon alors donc vous actrice
m'enfin bon c'était pas non plus évident
est l'année du bac vous commencez à
faire un petit peu d'aidé figuration
comme ça n'ont jamais fait de jeu mais
facebook est un soin jamais fait de
casting c'est à dire que pour m'a
proposé un jour de passer un casting
pour la figuration
et moi je me suis battu c'est tant mieux
j'ai une faim 500 francs pour marcher
dans la rue aujourd'hui
voilà une copine qui se passe ici
ils pourchassent enfants vous connais
vous pensez que vous allez traverser une
rue et comme on s'oblige en fait c'était
le c'était le premier rôle de l'ennui de
cédric kahn ou vous fait tourner la tête
de deux hommes un peintre est un prof de
philo passer leur demande leur avis à
quoi porter à l'écran vous ai tenu
pendant pendant tout le film bien la
rend plus qu'il faut lire là maintenant
vous avez beaucoup minci mais c'est vrai
qu'à l'époque vous sortiez d'un chagrin
d'amour
vous aviez pris 10 kilos non un nom mais
je le sais vous étiez baby sitter à vous
rattraper sur le goûter des enfants de
vernier non quand on y va booster sur
les enfants qu'elles gardent et il était
comme ça
cerci c'était grâce le chagrin d'amour
non ouais mais ça arrange et depuis ça a
l'air de cette responsable a besoin de
moi je m'en souviens plus bien il ya
vingt ans que j'ai peu de chagrin
d'amour tu t'étais venger sur bobby
belle des mamans fait sérieusement votre
famille beaucoup de beaucoup de gens
étaient enfin votre nom ou d'amitié des
peintres je le fait de poser nu c'était
pas un drame
c'est pour ça que dans les antilles si
c'est pour si ça rentre dans le cas
d'une oeuvre
tout ça me dérange pas poser nue ah bon
pas du tout ce qu'on avait dit oui
énormément
et puis c'est moravia quoi c'est pas moi
c'est très bien le film met ainsi la
duperie de luxe n'est pas par hasard
c'est un très bon film mais ce n'est pas
dans le tournage et c'est tellement
libre et votre nudité que j'ai oublié de
remettre le peignoir entre deux prises
c'est pas ça sert que j'aime pas trop
faire des six comme j'ai d'ailleurs eu
l'idée qu'il ya des gonzesses à celle de
son côté vais jamais joué lui voue
gérard darmon
non je joue avec un petit
un petit le petit string de la cité de
la peur là où il ya du tenu dans les
pruneaux j'avais marqué son centre est
puis en juillet n'ont pas la réponse
mais de la question je vous avais oublié
vraiment de vous réveiller après comme
si on oublie de se rhabiller après la
prise d'un méchant ça l'était donc
j'avais tout puisque incroyable vous été
choisi par cédric kahn au milieu de
trois mille si c'était pas et on a mis
beaucoup quoi c'est vous qui l'a choisi
et au moment où vous êtes choisis donc
ces seuils c'est le rêve absolu tout
s'écroule non c'est exactement ça
racontez-moi donc en fait j'ai passé un
premier essai j'ai fait je sais plus
quoi un texte du roman je crois de
moravia et là j'étais prise mais parmi
cinquante filles on va dire et là ça
s'est arrêté pour cause de production du
pognon quoi voilà donc ça après six mois
après au jir fait quand même trois
quatre et sterling et au bout si vous
mettez une serveuse dans un quick vous
avez travaillé euro disney c'était avant
pendant ou entre les deux serveurs
c'est une question d'éthique ou de taxes
oui l esthétique et à carreaux disney
effectivement mais sinon il est sympa
dingo dans la vie on connaît lé est ce
que vous préférez acheter vous préférez
plutôt ou plutôt bon et là le film se
fait donc le film sur des cannes ce fait
vous déboulez dans le cinéma français
c'est vrai qu'à une époque y avait des
actrices fait pas un peu aride quoi on
peut dire comme sandrine bonnaire ou
juliette binoche dans ce jeu vous
arrivez super pulpeuse comme ça dans un
costume d'écureuils qui avait échoué je
suis oise est
et donc voilà non c'était un choc parce
qu'on était plus habitué aux blondes un
peu généreuse quoi ça sert que du coup
on propose que ça et c'est un peu
dommage considère qu'on voit que comme
jeunes filles sexy
et c'est pas du tout envie de faire que
ça pour y être je pas ma serial-killer
mais sexy aussi donc c'est ça qui vous
embête c'est que voilà vous êtes juste
sexistes vous auriez de ses avocates
sexy serial killer sexy partout pourquoi
pas faire ça moi là la potiche vous êtes
magnifique dans l'ennui vous n'êtes
jamais impudique derrière même si vous
êtes promener tout nu comme disait
l'autre
vous avez déclaré l'impudeur c'est pas
détenu sur un écran ces deux clones et
des oreilles d'hommes sur des rats je
savais qu'on allait me la ressortir ce
qu'il a écrit l'autre l'a opposée elle
bon alors à faire un peu de promo
maintenant un agent c'est pas ça c'est
pas de faire ça cette page est très
libre à donchery que cette sèche linge
sèche c'est très vexant pour moi je
l'avais opprimés gg très petit bras je
l'essayé mais c'est très vous allez
essayer oui dans cette zone alors ceci
guillemin vous êtes membre du jury du
festival international du cinéma au
féminin du 18 au 24 septembre d'arcachon
1 la présidente c'est dominique sanda je
crois dans le jury à vincent elbaz
laurent maslé etc et des films en
compétition comme dans tous les
festivals
il ya aussi des films hors compétition
et d un film qui fait l'ouverture c'est
un film vous jouez qui est le fils de
jeanne labrune s'appelle ça ira mieux
demain
de quoi ça parle vous verrez
les ententes
d'accord d'accord d'accord c'est pas un
mauvais gars tu peux leur répondre
beaucoup mais un patron raconté way et
j'adore moi par exemple quand je vais
voir un film moi c'est moi j'ai je vous
posais la question imbécile de la
télévision mais tant pis pour vous vous
y êtes à votre avis ce fils du minck est
ce que les femmes apportent au cinéma
dans les tranquilles pendant 10 minutes
si tu as besoin d'aller faire un tour
ouais un peu cassée elles sont plus
d'observatrice elles ont raison elles
ont plus besoin de raconter ce qu'elle
voit et de presque raconter leur vie en
fin de ce qu'elles ressentent haut tout
là quelque chose de plus personnel voit
les gens ont du mal à intellectualiser
elle raconte vraiment au premier degré
tout ce qu'il a fait j'aimerais pourquoi
j'ai rien entendu mais et les hommes
souffrent fonctionne plus sur
l'imaginaire sur leur sur la fiction bon
ben si ça se trouve c'est non non c'est
une bonne réponse questembert public ça
tu es bien commun est bien sécurisé on
pense et gérard jeu poche peut tout à
fait d'accord mais on va dire oui mais
allez-y n'encaisse que les femmes
apportent au cinéma je trouve déjà que
de faire le distinguo c'est déjà ça non
je maintiens festival international du
cinéma au féminin une le fond une star
go soit moi qui les fais là justement
c'est ça que vous remettez en cause ou
absolument pas il est sympa distinguo ça
c'est drôle on peut applaudir par
exemple
merci infiniment
maintenant je vous faire une interview
première fois en bouche pendant le
génial
bondam première fois sais pas si l'un y
voilà la première fois la faute est la
première fois votre premier souvenir
mon premier souvenir de quoi de votre
vie la nième dit d'armand oui
effectivement votre premier souvenir
vous étiez tout petit petit petit petit
je me souviens j'étais amoureuse d'un
garçon en maternelle qui ressemblait
beaucoup au prince dont et amos
candidats les deux dessins animés les
vosges est amoureuse du but du prince
nous est amoureuse qu'on dit parce que
j'étais un peu comme candy est donc ce
petit garçon la maternelle qui était
réelle ressemble beaucoup à ce garçon
qui s'appelait anthony ou un truc comme
ça
et d'où j'étais absolument à monze luce
est fou mais j'avais mes meilleures
amies quête amoureuse lui aussi est donc
on les cours et après toutes les deux
comme des hystéries d'impôt de
maternelle et ont démontré en petite
culotte aaa
ça commence fort votre premier péché
péché oui j'ai wenyan un péché mortel
mon premier péché le premier est de
l'avis de gérard de la sienne las de la
vie de sophie premiers déchets premier
péché mais gégé pas vous le dire merci
non c'est un truc
ouais hein ouais tout seul donc bon on a
compris votre premier amour donc si je
vous l'avais dit c'était le petit
anthony la phase 6 qui ressemble au
prince quoi si on appelle ça un amour
ouais mais après il ya votre premier
amour amour quoi ouais c'était qui le
nom le prénom et nom voir qui c'est et
je vous dit pas le nom et le prénom make
way se mêlent 30 le long de
l'accouchement on va être un peu
difficile mais on va y arriver
non mais bon un mec d'accord mais à part
ça quoi c'est quel âge aviez 15 ans à 15
ans deux premières manches de 15 ans
après c'est trop tard
moi je trouve ça un peu tard non 50 à 16
ans maintenant brestois je parle des
petites amourettes oui d'accord d'accord
bon disons c'est à 15 heures que tout ça
s'est passé quoi ah ouais ben voilà
première fois à trois 3 ans non à 3,6
quand on était à 2 c 15 ans à 15h30 dans
la seule qu'on la fasse à 15h30
aboujerra part dans la première fois
deux fois ses lecteurs dans les années
70 moi j'aime mais moi je réponds parce
interview la pression est sûrement là
elles sont là pour qu'on a traversé les
années soixante dix première fois à
trois voire quatre là voilà voilà c'est
à peu près le même parcours que le vôtre
tant mieux pour vous ma première fois
qu'un premier chagrin d'amour donc oui
donc c'est celui où les gâteaux baby
sitter voilà d'accord j'ai compris 10 kg
d'un côté ce sont prés première
tentative de suicide pourquoi c'est que
le nutella satuc bon madame de fontenay
et son mari de catherine ce serait bien
qu'on va invite mme de fontenay ça peut
l'entendre là bas c'est quand tu veux me
dit catherine dans l'oreillette merci
qu'elle avait une offre de gendarmes
pour noël et étouffe
alors bon première première cuite je
sais pas vers 16 sept
avec le premier la fourche est ensemble
bien moribond non pas le match quand tu
demandes et de sa première fuite il m'a
dit je m'en souviens pas j'ai dit
pourquoi il m'a dit que j'étais bourré
premier pétard par harris était à
matignon c'était la bonne époque j'étais
là il fallait vous connaître en fait
première ligne jamais très bien c'est
bien vous avez raison
première chose que vous faites le matin
en vous réveillant à pisser je me bats
toujours pas du tout votre dernière
volonté si vous deviez mourir pis ses
dernières volontés si vous deviez passer
une soirée
j'ai accueilli